foreign
Tyson here your personal astrophysicist
we're doing an explainer Chuck you love
you some explainers of course I do
because I need everything explained to
me
that is where I live and so this is my
favorite that's your space the explainer
space explainer space so I want to talk
about Mars as a backup plan for Earth is
that a good idea is that a bad idea I've
done a lot of thinking about it but so
has friend of Star Talk Catherine heyo
Catherine welcome back to start talk
thank you for having me again yeah and
and remind me of your your full title
it's Catherine hey ho badass climate
scientist that is all you need to know
Neil oh you need to know
hahaha
okay badass climate scientist
um and Amer and distinguished professor
at Texas Tech did I get that correct you
did and then I'm also the chief
scientist for The Nature Conservancy
nature conservancy and where you run
programs there exploring uh climate and
all the ways that affect us yes so uh
you we all know that many people have
talked about
Mars is a backup plan get your ass too
much let's go back to Carl Sagan we need
our species on more than one planet in
case one goes extinct it's put you know
for whatever reason asteroid a killer
virus whatever so as a headline it seems
to make sense that Mars would be the
backup plan we've heard Elon Musk you
know that boy wants to go to Mars he's
good designing Rockets to make that
happen Stephen Hawking I forgot the
quote what was it Catherine that Stephen
Hawking said well you and I uh Neil were
at one of Stephen Hawking's last
starmus festive festival and he was he
was talking about how climate change was
a serious threat to the future of humans
and human civilization on this planet
and I was sitting there nodding along as
a climate scientist saying yes you're
absolutely right and then he said
something that completely shocked me he
said so that's why we have to terraform
Mars and I thought are you kidding yeah
yeah so this I don't think he thought
that through yeah um Stephen Hawking
what a loose cannon
God if only he thought things through
okay so what's your issue with it and
then I'll tell you what then I'll I'll
pile on after that what what was your
issue with this thought well first of
all say that you did terraform Mars
before human civilization self-combusted
due to the impacts of climate change who
would get there not the 8 billion people
just the you know the one percent of the
one percent of the one Elon and his
people exactly it's sort of like that
movie Kingsman where the guy was you
know basically trying to just save his
favorite people and then destroy the
rest of the world it it's completely
unfair if you could do it but I don't
think you could because what's at stake
here is not the planet itself it is our
civilization that is number one on the
chopping block and how are you going to
get to Mars if you have a civilization
that is just crumbling due to the
impacts of climate change
or plus you go to Mars and then trash
Mars now you need a third planet there
you go you need you know Earth plan C
right rather than a backup plan B but
that's not even my objection
Chuck why are you making a face
I'm just a humble farmer
a simple man with simple taste I just
just I just till the back 40. and no no
I'm I'm very practical minded in that
sense all right I'm an optimist but from
a very very I'd like to think I'm a
sensible Optimist right rather than a
dreamy Optimist and so here's how it
goes
it seems to me
if we're trashing Earth
in all the ways we are
with plastic in the oceans and and and
climate change and the carbon footprint
and all of this
if we're trashing Earth
and we figure out how to terraform Mars
it seems to me if we can turn Mars from
what it is today into Earth
then we can turn Earth back into Earth
you think so let's terraform Earth
exactly
if you could turn Baron dry cold airless
Mars into an oasis
that Gap seems to me to be larger than
whatever the hell we do to Earth to turn
it back into Earth that's my first point
that's why I don't think Hawking thought
that through
because that power of geoengineering
would enable us to fix Earth okay stop
talking you dumbass well I completely
agree with you and in fact when that
happened Martin Reese was right beside
me who of course is another astronomer
and I said do you agreement yes and this
is what Martin Rhys said he said oh no
fixing climate change is a dawdle in the
park compared to terraforming Mars yes
that's basically what I'm saying here
correct correct so that's my first point
hey Neil happy sweet 16.
what this is your 16th book coming out
the one that we started working on
together two years ago
this yeah
well thank you yes it's my 16th book
practically forgot about because I've
been very busy and I guess it's coming
out a month well it's my first book so
oh sorry we gotta do something sir so I
should be more excited that okay
absolutely
I met you guys but I think this is your
best one
second point
second point again considering
terraforming more isn't shipping a
billion people there just ask yourself
what could put us at risk going back to
the originals Carl Sagan concern that an
asteroid could take us out on Earth so
we need population on two planets my my
as it took out the dinosaurs so my issue
there is
whatever it takes
to terraform Mars and ship a billion
people there
it seems to me that's more effort than
deflecting an asteroid I'm just I'm just
spitballing here right I'm just thinking
if if you had that power then bat the
asteroids out of the way at will because
you'd have the power to accomplish that
as well and I can continue this exercise
with like a killer virus let's say okay
whatever it takes to terraform Mars and
ship a billion people there
it's probably harder than coming up with
a with with a a perfect anti-viral serum
that will protect us from all future
pathogens it seems to me that so
Catherine am I wrong here what where are
you on this no you are totally right we
humans are great at not wanting to fix
what's right in front of our face and
saying oh let's just go over there and
what this is is this is a syndrome that
I think we've had as long as there's
been human syndrome I like that do you
have a name for the syndrome I do what
is it it's the Flat Earth Earth syndrome
oh blood drawn yes we have been behaving
our entire civilization which isn't that
old you know six to eight thousand years
we've been behaving as if the planet
were flat and infinite that if there was
garbage or waste or pollution that we
need to get rid of we could just put it
far away and if we needed something more
we could go get it over there or take it
from someone else well the planet is not
flat and infinite it is emphasis on take
it from someone else
yeah well yes talk about four centuries
of colonization okay so go on yes yes
so so
this whole time as if there's always
something new and that and going to Mars
is just an extension of the Flat Earth
syndrome in my opinion wow and it's some
interesting sort of comedic moments
there do you remember was it in uh
was it that girl with Marlo Thomas so in
that girl so there's a scene where she's
on the Staten Island Ferry and her
boyfriend Donald okay unwrapped some
candy or something and he he and he just
he's ready to toss it uh overboard and
she she grabs his hand and has him put
it in the trash can okay this is very
very forward thinking of her then the
janitor comes up afterwards and takes
the entire trash can and dumps it into
the ocean Dad into the ocean so the idea
that you can belch forth uh smokestacks
and auto exhaust into the air and dump
garbage into the oceans is exactly what
you're saying Catherine that you just
like you said you dump it out over here
and get other stuff over there so it's a
flattereth syndrome ooh I love it
yes so what we need is uh we need a
black hole to dump stuff now that's a
great idea that's what we need yeah I
mean I I hear there's an offshore black
hole yeah all right and put all the
plastic all the and that black hole will
Don't Care What You're Made Of it'll
take you right to the singularity and
you'll be a pile of atoms at that point
right there you go uh what do you think
of my solution where's the closest black
hole
you thumbs up
so Chuck we just need a way to Corral it
and then you'd bring it close who's
gonna grab it without getting sucked in
so there's some practical issues that's
what poor people are for and um no
seriously that's how Elon Musk I'm sure
he's got a plan
okay we gotta call it quits there's been
a fast explainer but Catherine thanks
for sharing your perspectives
um along with mine on uh Mars as Earth
Plan B it's a bad idea let's fix Earth
with all of our genius that we know Walk
Among Us and all of our inventiveness
and Ingenuity because the I don't want
to die force can be quite potent with I
want to live right when you want to find
a solution so all right Catherine we'll
see you again next time Chuck always
good to have you always a pleasure all
right Neil deGrasse Tyson here signing
off for another start talk explainer as
always I bid you keep looking up
[Music]